yeah welcome to this video this is
different yep it's a different kind of
video that nothing what I usually done
but I actually intended to do something
else but when I logged on to teach Escom
the live game server there's some some
bullet going on between Hikaru Nakamura
and international master denny wrench
one of the administrators i think of
chess calm yeah let's see what happens
they just doing a small break here it
seems they played seven games they're
only here now now we on he carlos
leading 7-0 and it's 1-0 bullet so a
real deal no increment i'm going to do a
little bit of commentary but while it's
bullet chess so it's fast furious and
difficult to go to comments on yeah what
happens here he car was black has played
the modern and he is one of peace am in
lightning speed won the night on before
but white has two points so then he
still has some some some fight left in
this position and black cannot castle
this is not that easy to play in bullet
chess let's see how it goes down
yeah taking route i have one check and
white will try to use this activity the
knight on b8 is the extra might but it's
not doing much and white is very active
the bishop on d6 is super strong
actually think that why does probably
good him Queen Queen to f6 or Bishop f8
and now threatening Queen f8 major but
the Cairo is seeing all that stuff of
course very nice
then you push the H pawn so another unit
in the attack where we look at f6
intending group g6 but it didn't happen
okay switched over to f6 with this
Bishop but D for now is hanging yeah
like it's threatening to take d4 with a
check and white that's a tricky move
Queen d5 is maybe possible and it's not
clear what white should do we I think he
cares one this or he will win this he
has traded this important the
all-important Queens and Oh Luke a3 was
a blunder but it didn't it it wasn't
taken okay so eight zero for a Carol
yeah it's a it's a huge score but it
happens to for most all opponents they
get beaten terribly in bullet 1 0 & 1
plus Valley as well but there was super
quick time controls he Kara was really
probably with some kind of distance to
number 2 was the best player in the
world I think that magazine bashira
graph and de metrio and rake in that
they're also really good at bullet but
it's probably am yeah not not comparable
to turn a camera yeah here white has a
nice position out of the English opening
with Cindy for that's really nice and
oops
well c3 Hanks funny low tactic just for
a trait yeah Black has a nice night on
d4 but white will get some attacking
chances like Queen Queen over to h6
would be nice my attention there was the
coup de roca saying wow when he can he
cares just flood the room he had
problems with hanging pieces anyway but
let's see that's not over white still
has some challenges here trying to get
on those dark squares with the quick run
of the screen no I thought that's a
point for Danny wrench it was a little
bit too much and no
sakura-san lost more than 20 points it's
really difficult with a 500 point
difference that they have the cow has to
win like Holy's games yeah every draw is
like like a disaster yeah and while we
while we headed the camera is playing
one of those chests or calm death
matches on
I think the first Saturday in January
and he will play against West lay so so
this is excellent if you if you have the
child I think it should be the first
Saturday in in January check out our
chest column for further information
they have some information now about
this match yeah what happened here Dan
years why he's got an extra pawn but his
position is in disarray there's an
attack on g2 by Queen and Luke and the
Queen had nowhere to go
Wow - this is the kind of move that
really lives your stunts before I was
said necessary but note that Hikaru has
46 seconds and 10-year only 16 so the
time is a big problem and now he even
has three pawns of course cannot expect
the highest quality of movie and bullet
it's just lightning fast yeah it's very
difficult for white you still go for a
win here even with this extra piece
knight c6 maybe in 94 and to win the
pawn and now it gets it gets close to
something 94 yeah he gave away that one
so white is winning but he only has 7
seconds then he is really quick actually
but it's difficult relief he caught up a
lot in terms of time and now it's not so
easy just to stop the stop the pawn at
least in 52 where Wow
okay so it turned around again well he
only had like three seconds yeah like
I'm where I will win this from time and
on position yeah this wasn't
really forced or anything but what can
you do
Wow g4 it's funky okay it's it's it's
put a chest you can try all kinds of
things but yeah okay yeah Black has a
nice space advantage I think black
should be in good shape yep
but yeah if force is weak and like just
gave away the exchange but he has some
some play yeah the speed of play is
really really really high I mean Danny
wrench is not slow he's lying on 40
something seconds yeah it's really nice
but I come all right sir is an exchange
of it's just the simple counting
exercise and black it's not having
enough compensation and he will get the
e4 pawn but White's King this is a
little bit weak so you never know yeah
like sometimes Queen on d4 Queen B to
made white is covering that at the
moment but this kind of ideas can maybe
fall back on white okay you just want
this pawn on d3 night afore queen c5
could could have been move triumphal
made on c2 but probably possible to
cover it
Knight c5 maybe yeah black is trying to
try to stir up trouble and he managed he
managed he managed now he's to two
pieces of I can really screw this up I'd
see a black is winning and he has some
time he has actually more time on the
clock you know then your range is
reaching here 2500 I think it's a little
bit low oh for his bullet skills he it
makes it really makes a very nice
impression that's quick and he's not
doing something something stupid really
they are very nice he is totally winning
oops I know
at the point oh it's a premium fest yeah
very quick play very quick flame and
anyone on time whoo wow he's really
quick he's really quick yeah I think his
his bullet rating is - no to be honest I
think he's better than to five very very
quick stuff okay I hope they continue
for a little bit it's fun to watch and
I'm totally honest with you I was
sitting here already with ya with a can
of beer can of Guinness enjoying myself
a little bit and then I was seeing that
this is on so let's see I guess
disconnected okay maybe he's coming back
okay I'll have a I have a sepia of my
beer okay let's see if from he's
returning that was really really quick
yeah what what then he did there okay I
will wait a little bit maybe it's a he's
coming back so um this game has been
terminated but yeah not then he is
playing on a five-minute blitz game yeah
I'll wait for a moment if the cavalry
connects but probably it it won't happen
and it will just be this this small
video but it is nice that the David
Hockney was for 10 minutes so it would
be a little bonus video to be released I
hope you enjoyed it I think he will not
come back if you will I will edit a
little bit and add this to this video
yeah I hope you liked it it was just
like a little bit of fun thanks for
watching